have you guys started raising money oh
yes i'm sorry fully funded yes uh so we
are funded by two international
investment firms one based in london one
based in the new york area uh so it's
completely privately funded right now uh
we still have what do i i think
somewhere in the neighborhood of like 10
20 million in the bank but obviously we
know that it's a longer run to when we
actually go and start monetizing the
platform obviously the first aspects of
revenue generation won't come until
april and then where it really takes off
is this summer um but our backers know
that there's a lot of money quite
frankly to be made in this space we have
to spend a lot of money together a lot
of money a lot of money and that's and
here's the thing too as we talk about
kind of the peer dollar challenges just
being a competitor platform the extra
the way that the bar is raised extra
high just on attracting engineers
attracting talent because everyone is so
concerned about getting blacklisted by
google or facebook you know what would
happen if big tech saw that i worked
with a challenger uh would this you know
stop me from getting jobs or going to
the the cool parties uh in uh what a
great point put on a resume in nine
months i'd get her what were you doing i
get her two and a half years at getter
two and a half years at rumble i can see
that blacklisted permanently to work is
that a challenge for the engineers that
you're hiring or is that it so you know
i'll tell you on this it was at the
beginning it's less so now in fact a
couple of weeks ago we hired someone who
had competing offers from google and
from us and they turned down google they
came with us and i was like you know
holy you know what i'm like really like
you're turning on google to come with us
and the person said look i've been
impressed i was a little skeptical when
you guys launched i thought it might be
like the other platforms immediately got
kicked off or got banned i've seen what
you guys have done and i'm just so sick
of the discrimination he goes i'm not
even a republican i'm an independent but
the fact that if you're like if
independent in california basically
means that you're republican but you're
afraid to have your registration be that
which i can't blame them and he goes
just everybody knows like oh you're one
of them and he goes i'm just so sick of
that that discrimination that behavior i
want to go a place where at least look
he's not gonna be some card care and
republican at least he feels free so so
for youtube's alternative is rumble
every time youtube screws up rumble does
well krista as well and they get users
so the twitter's alternative used to be
parlor right parlor was the alternative
to uh twitter is that is that what was
was part of more a alternative to
facebook i think it was i think
obviously
let them describe themselves but
probably probably more of a competitor
to twitter
and i would say that where we started is
you just pull up on the screen our our
timeline our scroll
i would say initially most closely a
marketplace competitor to twitter very
clean by the way it's very clean our
engineers are good you know i i
when i first came on board i and i
obviously i i launched it but the other
engineers were working on before i came
on board the guy who started this he's
now like in his the elite engineer he's
now in his mid 50s went to usc undergrad
usc grad school worked for all the big
companies like mcdonald douglas and
oracle
and the brain on this guy is so great
our cto that we have in place now the
guy has five degrees from mit and when
he said that in the interview i was like
okay this guy's lying go run a
background check who has five degrees
from mit and he's like yeah i think like
school stuff is fun and i can do it in
the evenings and weekends like what's
wrong with it like this guy's brain is
so big our deputy cto went to xinhua
which is like the the harvard plus yield
plus stanford of china he's now here
living in the u.s and will be
permanently living here in the u.s the
brains on these guys are so big i mean
i'm just the pretty face uh but these
guys are that was that was a joke for
anyone who's not seen i like that i like
the way you do i'm definitely i'm
definitely
these guys are so smart because again
the two things that i said right at the
beginning i want this to be a global
company that can scale it has to look as
good if not better than anything big
tech is putting out otherwise people are
going to walk up and say yeah you know
twitter might be a bunch of you know
whats but their functionality is better
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]